[Music]
in the third millennium BCE early
astronomers from Mesopotamia mapped the
Stars giving names to constellations and
planets they called the Red Planet
Nergal after their God of War for the
ancient Greeks the celestial body was
likewise their God of War Ares ancient
Romans gave it the name we use today
Mars over a thousand years later in 1609
Galileo used the newly invented
telescope to get a closer look at the
red planet by the 19th century advanced
telescopes allowed astronomers to see
details of the planet's surface they saw
what came to be thought of as vast
canals surely evidence of civilization
people became fascinated with the idea
of life on Mars
and then in 1964 we did something those
Mesopotamian astronomers could only have
dreamed of we sent a craft the Mariner 4
on a 228 day journey to orbit the Red
Planet
Viking 1 touched down on July 20th 1975
and sent back the first images from the
Martian surface on NBC Nightly News
astronomer Carl Sagan
reacted to this unprecedented feat with
a characteristically broad perspective I
think it gets to something very deep in
in human nature the the will to explore
the lust discovery the curiosity I think
is something built extremely deeply into
us as a central part of our nature and
the earth is all explored here is a way
with inexpensive machines of extending
ourselves beyond our planet we since
landed seven more objects on Mars to
study topography and geography and in
the process learned that those canals
which incited such a frenzy turned out
to be nothing more than an optical
illusion
NASA landed the insight Lander on Mars
in November 2018 to finally explore the
interior structure of the
four-and-a-half billion year old planet
and give us a greater understanding of
all planetary evolution including that
of our own
[Music]
the next step may have been inevitable
since those ancient Mesopotamians first
began to look up from NASA to the United
Arab Emirates to the private company
SpaceX several disparate plans are
underway for us to make the greatest
journey in our history as a species
[Music]
will we get there Carl Sagan thought so
maybe we're on Mars because of the
magnificent science that can be done
there the gates of the Wonder world are
opening in our time or maybe we're on
Mars because we have to be because there
is a deep nomadic impulse built into us
by the evolutionary process we come
after all from under gatherers and for
99.9% of our tenure on earth we've been
Wanderers and the next place to wander
to is Marx
but whatever the reason you're on Mars
is I'm glad you're there and I wish I
was with you
[Music]
[Applause]
we are going to Mars humans we humans
are going to Mars there's a there's a
bunch of different plans to do that
Elon Musk says these will get there 2024
2025 NASA makes it more like 20 30 maybe
even 2040 it ain't cheap
musk who's going to send a crew of 12
says the cost will be more than 10
billion with a B per person other
estimates eclipse five hundred billion
so we can't exactly afford that here at
the World Science Festival but we can
take a hypothetical trip to Mars and
that's what we're going to do here this
evening giving all of us a sense of what
it might be like to take that long
dreamed of destination and of course to
take that journey through space we're
going to need a crew so let's bring them
out
Trekkies take note we all know that a
spaceship Nietzschean and needs an
engineer and we need our own captain
janeway and we have her at NASA she has
worked with boosters with environmental
control and life support systems
spacesuits and extra vehicular activity
tools she currently leads the Mars
integration group developing crewed Mars
missions concepts please welcome
Michelle Rucker
[Applause]
a ship's a doctor on our ship is also
necessary and ours was a colonel in the
United States Air Force where she served
as a senior flight surgeon
prior to her selection to the NASA
astronaut corps in 1996 at NASA's Ames
Research Center she was the lead
astronaut science liaison and strategic
relationships manager for Google and
other Silicon Valley programmatic
partnerships say hello to dr. Yvonne
Cagle
[Applause]
our science officer is not a Vulcan but
she knows about volcanoes she is the
principal investigator on the NASA
funded Hawaii space exploration analog
and simulation project or high-seas
which conducts long-duration space
exploration simulations on Mauna LOA's
on Hawaii a planetary geologist and
specialist in AI please welcome Kim
Binsted we couldn't go anywhere without
our ships captain
ours was the chief scientist at NASA for
more than 25 years working on missions
including the exploration of Mars Venus
and Saturn
she is currently director of the
Smithsonian's National Air and Space
Museum please welcome Ellen stofan
what a fail welcome to all of you and to
all of you and I'd like to take a moment
to acknowledge something that is of
course obvious but certainly bears
noting for more than a millennia Mars
the planet has been associated with
men to the extent that the symbol for
male is the symbol for Mars tonight we
change that eat your heart out Mark
Watney this is the future so our journey
tonight has three stages like like every
interplanetary journey a stage one is
going to be the launch stage two is the
voyage stage three our new home and of
course we're going to start with where
we have to start which is the launch how
to get us off of this planet and onto
that one more than a hundred million
miles away
we know how most Rockets how old Rockets
have launched you light a match you burn
something up it goes right a little
explosion and you're off works just fine
has worked so far but Michelle there are
some drawbacks to the standard launch
approach for Mars is that right what
what should we be looking at instead of
what we've looked at in the past so so
chemical propulsion is what we typically
use that's it's been a good standby for
economy of scale we like to launch
bigger and bigger systems the the system
that NASA is developing now the the
Space Launch System is a heavy lift
capability that's what we'll need to get
a lot of stuff either to the moon or to
Mars you can launch a lot of little
bitty rockets but that's it's it's nice
to be able to get some big systems up
there too so that so the SLS is in work
several of our commercial partners are
also working on on similar chemical
rocket propulsion systems there are some
and you're gonna ask me go ahead and ask
me ask me the question I wasn't going to
get there yes
about space elevator I mean we got to
get there but we'll get there on one
second let me before we do that what's
what percentage of the weight on a
rocket is fuel I mean the fuel is the
biggie when you're taking off yeah it
depends on which fuels you're using who
Yvonne probably has the the numbers in
her head for the shuttle I don't have
them off set up my head I know the
shuttle for itself I don't know the
exact number but I know the most of the
energy most of the power is just in the
making escape velocity get out of the
atmosphere
right so is there a reason why we can't
do it the same old way to get to Mars as
we've done with the shuttles we've done
it with everything else oh we can sure
we can but we got to go a lot further we
have to go a lot further we have to take
a lot of stuff with us as a longer
journey so we just need more stuff okay
that's what that's what a heavy lift is
important to be able to get a large
amount of equipment the supplies that
we'll need for a long-term okay now I'll
ask space elevator it's such an exotic
concept the idea of an elevator into
space is it real is it science fiction
so I'm not an expert on the technology
but my understanding is it's a
conceptually it would work there's some
limitations in the materials right now
there's a lot of research and
development being done NASA did a report
back in 2010 on Sky I think sky hooks in
space elevators and found that the
materials advancement just isn't quite
there yet for being able to make that a
reality from for earth potentially it
would work on the moon as well but right
now there's a materials advancement it's
just adjust up but can you give us the I
hate to say the elevator speech for the
space elevator what's the what's the
short version of exactly how it works
it's basically a tether with a
counterweight on the end so that begs a
lot of questions about operations here
on earth traffic management would be a
problem very long tether I at one point
in my career I worked on hypervelocity
impacts of spacecraft with space debris
or micro meteoroids so I would worry
about the tether being impacted if if
the tethers damaged what's your what's
your backup plan
so there's a lot of technical challenges
right now NASA doesn't currently have a
space elevator in the plans but if
anybody has a really good idea for you
the materials advancement I would
encourage you to go to Internet browser
and look up NASA it's NS NS RTF NASA
space research technology fellowships
NASA supports a graduate student
research we're always looking for for
clever ideas and new technologies new
advancements and materials and different
concepts so we would love to hear some
great ideas I hate to ask but are you
suggesting that we don't know how we're
going to get there thing is now there's
all these private companies that are
helping to reduce the cost to low-earth
orbit
you know SpaceX blue origin and if we
can start reducing the cost to low-earth
orbit that's gonna help bring the cost
of getting to Mars down right go ahead
Yvonne and for all you Trekkie fans the
old beam me up Scottie and believe the
space elevator is using microwave beam
power to help sort of accelerate a
vehicle up the tether and now one of one
of the interesting things is the
materials advancements that would need
to be made to make a space elevator work
those materials could also be applied to
traditional chemical propulsion systems
as well so it's it's not necessarily one
or the other the the technologies might
support either or or something nobody
has even thought of yet okay so that's
one possibility space elevator another
possibility the lunar orbital platform
Gateway what's that about oh yeah so um
Gateway is a concept that nASA has been
working on for about five years and the
idea is can we start to break that
independence from the earth and go out
to the vicinity of the Moon go into a
lunar orbit and basically have a smaller
scale space station that would be sort
of the test vehicle for the transfer
vehicle that would get you to Mars so we
need to make some improvements on the
space station we need to make sure the
systems are a reliable life support is
one of the most critical systems so
let's go test all those systems
out in the vicinity of the moon get
where we can get home in three days if
there's a problem and then we'll go on
to Mars after some you know a couple
years of testing in lunar orbit then
we'll be ready to go on to Mars it's
also a great platform to use to them to
send down to the lunar surface if
companies or countries want to go down
to the lunar surface it's a great
platform to do that from so we know how
to get to the moon we haven't lived on
the moon we've only gotten there this is
the moon base to Mars idea they would
set up a base and then is the idea that
we would go from the moon to Mars or is
it that the moon just gives us a sense
of how to function before we move on to
Mars you know people have looked at
different architectures because
obviously when you when you're on a long
term long time voyage to Mars remember
it takes seven to eight months to get to
Mars where I know we're gonna talk about
that in a minute but you're gonna want a
multi module craft because you're always
gonna want to have somewhere to retreat
to if something goes wrong and think
Apollo 13s
so the idea is are we gonna construct
that vehicle in lunar orbit out by the
Gateway and leave from lunar orbit which
is a lot less energy than trying to
leave from Earth orbit so people have
looked at different different scenarios
leaving from lunar orbit just takes less
energy so it's a lot easier we're not
doing this alone are we this is we are
now in the public-private world of space
exploration both SpaceX and Blue Origin
have ways to get to the moon on the way
to Mars that would talk about that a
little bit Allen how much how much is it
going to be a partnership I think it's
gonna be an incredible partnership and
you actually saw that on the Gateway
slide you saw all those different
acronyms up there what those were were
all the different space agencies of the
world so the European Space Agency the
Japanese Space Agency is JAXA the
Russian space agency wants to get
involved the Canadian space so all of
our partners from the international
space station want to go onto the moon
and on to Mars and even countries that
haven't been involved in the space
station everybody wants this to be an
international effort and then on top of
that we have all these private companies
so I think it's gonna be Internet
national it's gonna be public private
and frankly that's the only way I think
we're going to get there this is a big
change certainly from the days of the
race to the moon and our rivalry with
the then Soviet Union today we're seeing
a very different thing Yvonne I wonder
what the feeling is in the astronaut
corps about the idea that this is a
global enterprise rather than USA and a
flag and all that it's very exciting
it's an opportunity to be collaborative
and we recognize that the space race is
no longer between countries but actually
between industries and technology and
capability and if we work together we
can synergize and really go further
faster longer there was a time when we
all believed I think that NASA was the
only place that had the kind of
technology that we trusted and that we
believed in that's also changed that
well I mean how does NASA work with
private companies now in order to keep
that level so high and there and keep
the safety so high well fortunately NASA
and the whole international effort of
going to space is something that
everyone has a part of so the people are
globally and we're taking that global
expertise and no longer centralizing it
at NASA but decentralizing it into
industry and other areas and so what
this actually does is that that expert
talent is something that we can
outsource but I don't mean outsource by
taking it outside the agency or the
country but by taking it off planet and
what we can demonstrate off planet we
can bring back and actually help us here
with our lives in our environment right
here on earth okay let's get back to the
actual launch Michelle the determination
has to be made at some point what time
to launch and exactly when to launch how
do you make that determination what are
the factors that go into that so to go
to Mars so Mars and Earth chase each
other around the Sun there are different
orbits and they're traveling at
different speeds and about every 26
months there's an optimum alignment
where
you have the minimum amount of energy
needed to get from Earth to Mars which
means they're closest not necessarily
closest so the analogy we like to use is
if you're passing a ball to someone you
don't someone who's running you don't
aim it where they're at now you aim it
where they're going to be right when you
think the ball will arrive and how hard
you throw the ball is equivalent to how
hard we have to throw our spaceships you
can throw it harder but it takes more
energy and that translates into more
equipment or more propellant right it
could be more money so you want to be
able to do the easiest throw that you
can do and that happens about every 26
months every 26 months is there also a
time of day and what if that every 26
month is bad weather I mean do you have
a window yeah there's a several days of
window on either side of that the
optimum time but only several days I
think I've it kind of depends on which
system each each opportunity is a little
bit different and it varies a little bit
from year to year okay we're going to
move on now to the actual voyage we have
now figured out how to get there whether
it's the elevator or whether it's some
combination of the elevator and or
heavy-lift and whatever we're now on our
way whether we've gone from the moon or
from here let's talk about this trip
first of all give or take 100 million
miles is that right 140 hundred million
something like that so the the number we
like to use is if you look at the
odometer on your spaceship to get to
Mars and back again it's about two
thousand times as far as going from here
to the moon the the numbers themselves
are so big they're hard to wrap your
head around sometimes but two thousand
times as far as it is to the moon that
sort of puts it into perspective and
that's the round-trip journey Yvonne let
me start with you
we're now on this voyage we're now going
to Mars how long is it going to take Wow
well it depends if we're doing it with
or without a lunar assist which is
basically your slingshot my preference
is a slingshot but if we were to do with
the traditional way we're looking at
somewhere around nine
months when we put Landers or probes or
vehicles it's been about you know not
quite a year maybe somewhere between six
to eight months but for humans since we
have to take a little longer route we're
looking at nine months traditionally if
we do something that is more of a
vehicle energy boost we can get it down
to six months but then you're basically
a human projectile having a gravity
assist that's accelerating you into the
Martian atmosphere through the
atmosphere into a very kind of
accelerated landing back up for a second
why do humans why does it take longer
longer to sent humans partly because of
the human body itself and also because
of the kind of weight and supplies the
extra weight that will weight mass since
there's no weight in space mass it will
be carrying so when you put on human
bodies or stuff that you're taking both
I like that less now that we have 3d
printers so we'll be able to sort of
manufacture things additive
manufacturing where we're going so we
just have to bring the component
materials but they're still going to be
some gear and quipment that we'll need
to - let's let's talk about the stuff
what are we taking with us who wants to
talk about what we're taking along let
me just go back a little bit to what
you've unsaid so the biggest thing we've
landed on Mars to date it was the
Curiosity rover that's about one metric
ton with its like the size of a
[Music]
something yeah you all know about
curiosity of course the wonderful sweet
little Rover that's a TV like a TV okay
fine
so this is that biggest thing we've
landed successfully on Mars so if you
want to land a crew of four now the
rover didn't need a life-support system
it didn't need you know food it didn't
didn't need a potty so the humans are
gonna need a lot more stuff stop that
let these guys talk a little bit more
about this stuff but we're thinking on
the
order of about 20 times as much mass as
curiosity for a human-scale Lander so
it's a it's a it's a bit of a jump in
size
go ahead cam so a lot of the heaviest
things that we're going to need to send
our things like food and water as well
as all the equipment to keep humans
alive and so that's why one of the
factors in these mission designs that's
so important is Institute resource
utilization and what I mean by that is
if you have to bring all of the water to
get your crew there to keep them alive
on Mars and to bring them back home
again that's a lot of water and that'll
severely affect the mission parameters
but if you can send ahead an automated
system that can extract some of the
water that's already on Mars and make it
usable for humans then that cuts out
roughly two-thirds of what you need and
that's that's that makes a huge
difference and it makes some of these
missions much more fees but that's still
a piece of equipment somehow or some
version of a machine that has to be sent
there right but you'd want to send it
first because you'd want to be really
really really sure that it's working so
before before we have launched us we're
doing this hypothetical trip here five
of us and all of you by the way
so before we've launched have we sent up
a bunch of stuff yes almost certainly
that has stuff that has unpacked itself
or is it waiting for us dumping it's
unpacked itself it has hopefully
extracted water it's hopefully taken
some of that water and taken extract
some oxygen from it and hopefully has
generated enough fuel to send us back
again so that when we get there our ship
home is already waiting ready to go so
this is all robotic obviously so we said
so we're sending our our home our our
water system and a bunch of other things
they have this power you need power to
run all of the robotics so so surface
power ends up being a really key one of
the first elements
how many launches before the humans
launch for one mission it's you know the
estimates have been anywhere from four
to eight launches and obviously you
could go up as much as you want it just
depends on exactly how much you're
trying to you know pre position and this
is all of the assumption that nobody
there is going to wreck the stuff that
we're sending up there okay no little
green people we're good an opportunity
we're only supposed to survive on Mars
for ninety days and look at how long
they survive so robotic precursor
missions will go you know up to two
years before we actually landed up to
two years oh so we could start sending
them soon ish yes okay
especially this issue in fact the Mars
2020 Rover is actually going to do this
first practice of in situ resource
utilization it's actually gonna be
pulling carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere and basically putting it in a
tank that's a really simple first step
but it's a first step towards this so
we're already about to start practicing
this but the longer we have system is in
place to start extracting water
extracting carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere the better off we're going to
be exciting okay let's get back to our
actual we're now in the ship we're on
our way
Yvonne let me get back to the medical
stuff start with radiation oh we know
about radiation it's worse the further
the closer to the Sun obviously but the
further up what are the dangers what are
we dealing with well it's interesting
that you talk about that actually the
the most the greatest risk we have of
radiation exposure is actually closer to
the planet than you would expect because
it's the GCR Tsar galactic cosmic rays
and this is just a kind of hosh Posche
of a lot of ionized material that's very
close just outside our atmosphere
between earth and the moon so actually
the moon has a greater risk of exposure
than the deeper we go into space now the
deeper we go into space close
son now you have your alpha particles
and solar flares and a lot more
penetrating and damaging radiation so
it's just kind of do you want the direct
hit or do you want kind of the ripple
effect and what do we know about
radiation exposure on Mars itself well
the atmosphere is much thinner and so
we're going to definitely need to
protect ourselves and what we've looked
at is shielding the vehicle the route
there is really even a greater risk
so shielding let's stick to that for now
then okay so how do we shield ourselves
on the way there and and is there a
danger to the vehicle as well as to
ourselves yes both both the greatest the
best radio protectant is water but
obviously the up mass of that is not
just cost prohibitive but we just can't
bring enough water for that to that end
we're looking at things like titanium
we're looking at different complex or
carbon composites lots of different
materials that can be radio protective
even when we get to the moon the
regolith which is a soil on the moon is
somewhat radio protective as well
the big challenge will be on Mars with
having such a thin atmosphere how do we
best protect ourselves and that'll
influence where we place our habitat
will it be on the surface or will it be
somewhere beneath the surface where we
can have some protection from the
radiation okay we'll get to that but
when we get there we're not there yet
we're still only transition phase one of
the things they've been looking at and
this is even for the lunar gateway but
then certainly for the Mars transfer
vehicle is if you if you actually did
take enough water because obviously
we've got to take water let's use it
smart if you line where the crew are
sleeping with protective water that way
you far reduce if they're say 12 hours a
day they're in a radiation protective
area it reduces overall risk but you
can't do that in the ship on the way to
the entire ship but you can't around the
sleep quarters the whole way yeah so a
water barrier a water barrier just
around this water feature as we say
exactly another thing we're looking at
is just the the cargo the consumables
the food for example storing that in a
way where you take advantage of the
because that could also get damaged by
radiation or not so much food food is
pretty sturdy and okay deliberately a
radiate food on earth so that's true
Evon one more for you before I move on
to Kim and the psychological issues
Ivonne there the space stew I assess the
space station has given us an
opportunity to learn about individuals
humans living in space mark and Scott
Kelly famously the twins study when one
of them was on in the ISS and one was on
earth what have we learned that helps us
know how to manage our bodies for this
eight to ten month journey to Mars well
very quickly let me characterize besides
being a human aquarium surrounded by
water so that your radio protected the
other way that you can protect yourself
from radiation is to actually have your
stem cells drawn before you leave the
planet and basically have them carried
with you preserve them and be able to
sort of harvest them and replant them if
we were to take a big radiation hit so
we would quarantine ourselves for
several weeks or more and then slowly
allow our bones kind of to rehire vest
our blood supply and give us back that
immunity because that's where radiation
does affect us it reduces our immune
capacity along with some other
conditions the other thing that can
happen is when you first go into space
your blood volume starts to float
towards your head and it congest your
ears and kind of gives you this kind of
foggy space brain initially but over
time it can affect your your your focus
to some degree but your a vision you can
become more farsighted we're seeing the
other things that can happen is it can
change your taste and actually make
foods and medicines harder to absorb
because of some of the congestion that
happens in your stomach so how do we
guard against that well the important
thing and Kim will talk about it is
being very smart about our nutrition
changing it up so that we don't get
space anorexia which comes from appetite
fatigue eating the same thing
same texture same colors over time the
other thing that we can do is find
different ways to administer medicines
maybe through the nose nasal sprays as
opposed to having to ingest it in some
cases if we get sick or injured our
surgeries need to be done through a tube
so that we're able to contain our body
fluids you can just like somebody open
in microgravity everything floats
absolutely and the other concern is
certainly with our bones demineralizing
or thinning out and our muscles
weakening that affects our heart and our
ability to exercise our exercise
tolerance and that can very much not
only affect our performance but if we
were to get injured if we were to strain
a muscle or ligament or break a limb
we're going to heal very slowly and that
might be enough time to slow down our
resiliency and our strength and turn us
from a Mars visitor to a pioneering Mars
welcome-wagon committee but we don't
come home as quickly as we would have
anticipated which is not necessarily a
bad thing but why all the things you're
describing are are as a result of what
we've learned about long-duration space
travel and so we know how to deal with
some of the physical issues that may
affect our bodies Kim let me turn to you
now we've you know the five of us I've
had lovely chats in the green room we
get along just fine for you know the
last hour we're going to be on this
spaceship for eight to ten months Kim
how do you figure out the optimal cruise
so that we don't close each other's eyes
out it's a real problem you know if you
were to so I run a Mars analog habitat
in Hawaii and what we do is we take
groups of six people and we put them in
a habitat and have them pretend that
they're on Mars for four to twelve
months and we pick people who are very
astronaut like in their psychology
because one thing we already know is if
you just picked six people off the
street and did this they would be
killing each other within days what's
what's an astronaut like psychology well
there's a lot of
a lot of different tests but colleague
summarized it as thick skin long fuse in
an optimistic outlook and to that for a
Mars trip I would add easily entertained
because if you really need to go
clubbing every weekend or if you you
know need to meet new people or need to
go climb a mountain every day you're
you're not gonna have a good trip so you
know the kind of personality types you
need what about putting together a crew
we need one of these one of these one of
the how do you do that so yeah you're
gonna need a bunch of different skill
sets you're also gonna need not an
addition to the technical skill sets a
bunch of different approaches to
conflict resolution to leadership
followership and so on so I like to
liken it to a toolbox if you're filling
a toolbox you wouldn't filled it with
hammers even if they were all the
world's best hammers and you also
wouldn't fill it with Swiss Army knives
because there's a compromise that comes
with having all of those identical sets
of skills instead you want to have
people with strengths in different areas
with different life experiences with
different approaches to interpersonal
reaction interactions and so on and
that's that's really how you go how
about relatives is a good okay I'll give
you two at once
relatives marriages okay so I'm not
turning it down completely but there's
some risks with that as you might
imagine and one of the risks is a rift
with the rest of the crew if two people
have a very close relationship that
could break them off into a subset and
you really don't want to cause those
rifts in any way another way you caused
rifts is by having sort of clustering so
for example imagine you had a crew of
three men and three women three people
from a civilian background and three
from a military background a three
engineers three scientists fine that
sounds all right but we don't want to
have is three female civilian scientists
and three male military engineers
because
they're gonna split into those two
groups so you try and avoid those kind
of alignments as much as possible so
that I think is the risk with those kind
of close relationships that you're
talking about what about in day let's
say eight we have a fight they're not
gonna have it in day eight
I'm betting at about the six-month mark
that's what we see in our simulations
basically you know you've got these
people who are actually really good at
getting along with each other they've
got a lot of these interpersonal skill
sets because you work at it I mean you
think about this and you're yeah we can
do that we can work at this what we
found I think NASA would have loved it
if we could have come back and said look
avoid factor X and you won't have any
conflict but it's just not the case
anytime you have a group of people
together for that long you're gonna have
conflict and it comes from all sorts of
different sources interpersonal issues
stresses from back home disagreements
over something important but what you
really do need is to have this
resilience to conflict you need to have
individuals in a group of people who
could have a conflict and then come back
from it and return to a high functioning
state and is there some kind of chain of
command that's important like a military
chain of command yes there'll be a chain
of command we haven't found that the
style of command matters all that much
you could have the military very
hierarchical style or you could have a
more consensus driven style but one
thing that's really important is that
the style is agreed on right and that
your leader and your followers share the
same style or can share the same style
is it a democracy or is it somebody's in
charge
I voted is what you're looking for but I
I imagine that any commander on this
kind of mission is going to have to be
good at listening to the rest of the
crew okay Ellen and Michelle talk about
what we may have learned from Mir the
then Soviet space station and ISS what
have we learned about people getting
along together Ellen well we've
certainly learned how to live in space I
mean a lot of the lessons that we've
learned from high seas are the exact
same lessons we've learned in space it's
how do we get along how do we get past
conflict how do we understand roles in
abilities how do you bring people
together from different cultures to
solve problems and how do we get all
these systems to work reliably and
that's obviously been what we've been
doing up on the ISS and I it blows my
mind we've had what now 17 continuous
years of living in space continuously
they're up above us it's it's amazing
and if anybody hasn't ever looked at the
appspot the station if you if you google
the website and about every two weeks
the ISS comes over New York City and you
can look up and you can see it you can
wave to them I can't see you but it's
incredible to me you look up there and
you say ah there's six humans in space
above us how magical is that one thing
I'd like to add to that is as you
suggested the space systems are systems
of systems and subsystems and subsystems
and the human systems are part of that
so if the human part of that system of
systems breaks it can be just as
catastrophic as if the rocket blows up
right so we need to understand how these
all these things work together and test
them over these years and years of
operations
well surely one of us is going to have a
bad day but worse than that there could
be actual mental health issues
depression doctor what do we do about
that well for one thing the sleep
deprivation so when we're in space we
were sleeping last there's lots of
excitement going on there's lots of work
and sleep deprivation can make I don't
know tolerances and coping ability it
starts to erode it over time right so
sleep is one of the most important and
not just number of hours deep
restorative sleep and that means you
have to adjust the lighting during the
day but also during sleep it means that
you have to exercise to keep your body
and your whole lymphatic system
mobilized in moving so that you can
really refresh in detox and be able to
be restful when you do go to sleep
nutrition is a very important part of it
and all of these things along with
diversion and some distraction or on the
entertainment side can really help to
keep people from getting too wrapped
around the axle and keep things sort of
restored and refreshed so that's the
most
important thing of all what have we
learned from the this continuous
occupation a habitation in space what
have we learned about entertainment what
works what's a good thing to tell people
to bring it varies but things like
exercise that's probably the best of all
movement then it would have to be some
sort of artist artistic persuasion
something along the lines of music or
writing looking out the window taking
pictures finding some way to express and
share and communicate attachment having
some connection with family and friends
and and even what's happening in the
news on earth is very important to that
sense of attachment and then just being
able to which means communication back
to earth has to be established it has to
be continuous right for our 8 to 10
months trip to Mars do we have constant
communication with earth not constant
often we lose our signals and when we
reacquire that signal there can be
communication delays and one more on
moon on well moon there's three minutes
in most cases but on Mars there's a 20
minute delay each way so you can have
4045 minutes before and that's something
that you can make for an awkward
conversation but it's not much different
than on earth with some individuals but
but I will say the one thing that's very
important in terms of working together
is having people on the crew going
long-duration who are able to not just
take space but give space so on shorter
missions when it's two weeks long you
can have someone who's a life for the
party and entertaining but when it's two
years long then you want someone who's
able to give space in a very small
environment and that's an art in itself
that's its big decision go ahead Kim I
just wanted to add we stumbled across an
interesting way to stay in touch with
home during high seas one of our crew
her she'd brought some barrettes for her
hair and they broke so she emailed her
family and asked
try and find a 3d printable barrette and
they weren't able to find one or they
found one and then they were able design
pretty flowers on there and stuff that
she liked they sent her the design and
she printed it at the habitat so this is
a way you could imagine you know your
kid back home does an art project you
scan it in and then you can print it out
at the station so it's a way to go ahead
speaking of broken equipment yes what
we've learned on Space Station one of
the most interesting things from from
the work I did was when things would
break initially in the space station we
had what we call the orbital replacement
units we would just bring the whole
thing home on the shuttle send up a new
one because the shuttle was going back
and forth and it was fairly easy to do
when the shuttle stopped flying with we
had the accident and it was grounded we
had to learn to repair things in orbit
that weren't necessarily designed to be
repaired and so when you're taking apart
fine machinery with little tiny
itty-bitty screws that they could be
floating away from you in microgravity
that's very challenging and so so it was
a learning process we we would send the
instructions to the crew in some cases
we had video that would send up to them
will you even get their families
involved in some cases with you know to
say hello and do the video and the
repairs and one of the ones I remember
was the the treadmill exercise is
important and the treadmill had some
problems and so we sent up the
instructions the treadmill was taken
apart on orbit and repaired on even
though it was not meant to be right done
that way but you figured out a way and
we figured I would do that so so one of
the challenges for going to Mars because
it's such a long trip right if things
break we can't just send a new no you've
got to figure out what I'm thinking of
the early shuttle days and the famous of
the flyswatter when they had to reach
reach a switch and and configured
something that looked like a fly swatter
to make it work that Rhea Seddon did
which was quite a quite I mean very
inventive these things can happen and
yet to use what you have on board is
okay that's what's one thing you can
invent unless you have the right tools
is food what are we going to eat on this
trip now we're trying
to pare it down as much as possible we
can't take every single thing we want
food
well let me revisit this when we were
actually on the surface of the planet
because the food we're gonna be eating
on the way is pretty similar to what
they're using on ISS and it has to be
because in microgravity it is really
hard to cook you could put the food in
the bowl and it floats out again so yeah
pour your sauce on your pasta everywhere
[Laughter]
but let's revisit this when we get to
the surface okay fine so you're going to
assure me that there's room for all the
prepackaged things that I'm gonna heat
up in the little whatever they're
heating up equipment is on the on the so
for eight or ten months I'm gonna eat
space food basically exactly dehydrated
food that you just add water to and wash
it up and it's kind of ready to eat but
I will say this is one of the many areas
where things we developed for space
actually have a real and important value
back here on earth because if you think
of food that has to last for months and
months if not years and be stable and
not go bad and be able for example to be
may be sent into disaster zones or
places on earth where people are
starving having NASA space food actually
has huge benefits to people right here
on earth
that's another area when I talk to young
people there's a perception that you
have to be a rocket scientist to do what
we do
but there's a lot of different aspects
of a spaceflight so if you like to cook
food if anyone out there likes to cook
you know food research shelf life
stability just the packaging there's
just a lot you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to participate in a space
mission that's that's kind of a key
point that I try to talk with young
people about you can be a space foodie
and more let's talk about our home on
the way there what does it look like
what are we flying in I mean the
original the original the mercury the
Gemini capsules were pretty small
shuttle was obviously larger
are we somewhere in between are we
bigger what's that what does it look
like the vehicle it's gonna have to be
bigger I mean there's because you're
it's just too long and you've got to
have a separate place where people can
sleep you've got to have separate
modules for safety purposes as I said
earlier because you've got to have
alternatives for people to go but the
smaller it is the better can you get can
any of you give me a design concept I
mean there's something up on the screen
now is it going to looks like sort of a
dirigible or what what's it going to
look like a blimp I mean one of the big
debates is whether or not you try to
simulate gravity so one way to do that
is to well there's many ways one is the
kind of wheel design that you saw in I
think thousand one two thousand one had
that another is a tethered system so you
have your ship and maybe a weight or
another ship and you world around like
this but there's a lot of risks that
come with that kind of spinning as you
imagine if something goes wrong gone
yeah a lot of the designs most of the
designs we're looking at these days
don't do the artificial gravity route
although it would have a lot of health
benefits right and if we're looking at
you know Paul Ryan for example is a
capsule and it's a smaller version so
it's really going to have just travel
writing space there's not going to be a
lot of limp living work type of space
going on and so one of the things that
we've talked about and we're looking
into is human hibernation putting us
into suspended animation where our
metabolic or physiologic our body rate
is slowed way down sort of like if you
were to do cold immersion so that we can
sleep for the majority of it and then
when it's time wake up get our systems
going again and we're off and running
with this precursor robotic precursor
habitat that's just waiting with this
fine beautiful feast in water and
everything that will be the Welcome
Wagon the Welcome I got it okay so all
the way there incidentally is their
constant fuel happening is their
constant propulsion or are we somehow in
a in an orbital field where we
don't need that how what do we need to
get there so there's a couple different
options for for in space propulsion one
of the ones really Gantt now would be
used for free gateway the solar electric
propulsion the the guys I work with the
analogy they uses solar electric
propulsion it's a it's a low thrust it's
it's like being fifth gear in a car so
it's a nice steady very efficient method
and it's constant or it not necessarily
you're making course corrections but
when you need longer burns to do your
maneuvering a solar electric is a very
efficient way to do it chemical is is
good it's like first gear in a car it
gives you that oomph to get outta get
out of traffic there we've been looking
at hybrid systems that maybe take the
best of both worlds in one package how
about nuclear a nuclear is that's an
option there's a lot of research being
done on that so there are different
different possibilities together there
okay
we're almost there now you got a Landis
how do we land on the surface the tough
part that's the hard part it's the hard
part yeah entry descent and landing is
going to be the hardest thing and the
issue is that Mars has it obviously has
a lot more gravity than the moon had but
it also has an atmosphere but the
problem with ours is atmosphere is
there's enough of an atmosphere there to
heat you up as you come in but there's
not enough atmosphere there to really
slow you down so if anybody's seen the
great JPL video they put together before
curiosity called seven minutes of Terror
they really well explained that that
terror of entering the Mars atmosphere
so you have to really do things like how
do you slow down when you're coming in
at hypersonic speeds and it's it is not
an insurmountable problem it's just
tough and we've got to figure out how to
do it for a lot more than the one metric
ton of mass we landed at Curiosity
where's them there's some really
interesting technologies being developed
there's an inflatable technology we call
it the hi add the hyper hypersonic
inflatable aerodynamic decelerator
because we like really big words but
then we just call it the high hat
because
nobody can say all that or then you make
up an acronym that none of us can
remember yeah so this is that's an
inflatable technology there's another
deployable basically deploying large
surfaces to get you that that
aerodynamic assist when you're when
you're trying to enter and land
retropropulsion that bets another we're
used to that so yeah from Apollo it's
certainly in Gemini one of these really
an is for some of the some of the
precision landing that we'll have to do
on the moon can we take those
technologies and mature them enough and
then be able to use the same thing for
Mars without having to start fresh for
Mars you use as much of the technologies
as possible but unlike the shuttle it
will not land like an airplane on the
surface of Mars because of the
atmosphere there is one concept that
looks something like that
there's a we call it the mid L over D
concept but there's a runway it would it
would be more like a you know there'd be
Rockets to slow you down when you got
close so it's got to come in vertically
or some version of that to the way we're
used to seeing things it's gonna be some
combination you know it like curiosity
it's probably gonna use a combination of
things to slow it down probably ending
with parachutes but I always want to
point out for as daunting as some of
these things we're talking about seem
like in this year fiftieth year of
celebrating humans landing on the moon
for the first time remember at where we
started from and eight-and-a-half years
later we were actually standing on the
moon we we are so far ahead of
understanding what exactly the
engineering challenges are we're so far
down the road on them though so I get I
get stressed when people start thinking
oh my gosh this is such a hard thing oh
my God we're so far ahead of where we
were when we started out in the moon
okay we've done it
oh maybe ten months in we're not we've
landed and we've landed safely and we're
here and our robotic earlier ships have
set up everything that we need here we
are first thing let's talk about is in
order to
simulate what we will be living in in
this environment a number of places are
building habitats to simulate what it
would be like on Mars and I I think we
have an image or the one of the many
images the United Arab Emirates are
planning to spend a hundred and forty
million dollars to build a Martian
prototype city outside of Dubai as
preparation there are a number of these
things happening in other parts of the
world as well Kim you've done a lot of
these simulations
how long does one go into one of these
simulations how long do they last it
varies so at high seas we're one of the
longer ones so our longest mission was
12 months how many people that six
people in a small space about a thousand
square feet so a smallish apartment in
the rest of the world in New York it's
mission the Russians did one for 520
days a few years back which is the
longest one on record but there's also
what we call serendipitous analogs so
those are these mission like conditions
that kind of happen by accident so that
includes Antarctic exploration
submarines jail populations to some
extent and we've learned a lot from
those as well and what have we learned
well in addition to the stuff we were
talking about earlier so one is the crew
composition is really important another
is that supporting crew over this time
is really important do we have a
separate living quarters you know we do
at high seas and we think it's important
to be able to separate sleeping quarters
separate sleeping quarters that is so
ours are very small there gosh I don't
see anything comparable in size but a
little bit bigger than a small single
bed
but they have a really key component
which is a door that shuts and locks
having that little bit of privacy that
personal space is really important
what's the describe the atmosphere
atmosphere I mean in the in the broadest
sense what's it like what does it look
like on Mars what happens we've just
landed what do we see sorry
it'll be dusty it'll be dusty
I'm kind of pink dusty right the dust
from an engineering that's one of the
engineering challenges if the dust coats
our radiator panels our thermal systems
won't be as efficient so we have to
figure out how to keep the dust off the
the radiators same with solar arrays if
we if a coat solar arrays it'll reduce
the efficiency is it dusty everywhere on
Mars or just in certain areas there's
seasonal dust storms we're getting a
little bit better at it we're not
predicting weather in Mars but we're
sort of tracking things a little bit we
you know we haven't been watching Mars
that long and so you have to kind of
look at it seasons over a long period of
time to get the hang of the patterns but
the dust storms seem to follow specific
tracks and and they seem to be seasonal
so that helps us kind of be able to
predict what we have to deal with but
but dust if you if you bring dust into
your house it's kind of an annoyance
just to keep it clean if you bring dust
into your habitat and it gets into the
seals and you try to close the door and
this and the the internal pressure is
leaking that could be a hazard so we
have to pay a little bit of attention to
that that's one of those things that
we'll learn about on the moon alright
but what are we fighting on Mars and I
say fighting because we're humans were
used to a certain set of circumstances
that enable us to breathe to walk to
live what have we got
lay it out what's the situation on Mars
hey kelan extreme temperatures so it
never gets much above say the freezing
point and it can get quite quite cold so
that's certainly something we're gonna
have to be conscious constantly aware of
radiation so Mars doesn't unlike the
earth does not have a magnetic field so
that radiation we experienced in space
okay it's not as as as bad maybe as at
the moon but there's still a lot of
radiation hitting you on the surface of
Mars we've measured that with an
instrument on the Curiosity rover so
it's pretty well characterized let's see
what else it's one of the things that I
think is good is it's it's not that
alien of a landscape you know if you've
been out in the desert in Utah or some
places in the Middle East I mean those
landscapes on Mars which a lot of you
saw on the Martian aren't
that dissimilar the pressure is very
different so we have to be in
pressurized spacesuits all the time or
in a pressurized it happens not in a
pressurized spacesuit what have you done
right quickly essentially your blood
boil I mean yeah your blood boils and
okay so if we're gonna live on Mars for
any amount of time we must always be in
a spacesuit or for outside and we must
always be in a sealed environment of
some kind to be inside to eat to sleep
to work can't open the window or the
door look let me just first ask the this
the simplest question which is what does
that do to the human psyche not to be
able to breathe outside not to be able
to go outdoors it's one of the things
the Astros I mean Vaughn can talk about
sooner than I can but it's one of the
things when a lot of the astronauts will
say when I'll say what's the thing you
miss the most being on the space station
and let's say the wind on the face the
smell of the air the smell of rain so I
can I hear so I did one of these
missions up in the Canadian High Arctic
so we were sealed in for four months not
only going outside and spacesuit and
when the mission was over we walked
outside without our spacesuits and it
was amazing it like you'd gone from a
little black-and-white TV to this super
high-def world and there wasn't much to
smell but it was still a nice clean
smell out there for an hour and then we
went back into the habitat and it stank
[Laughter]
happy place and we hadn't realized it
because of course we've been in it the
whole time so is there
Yvonne is there a psychological effect
to not being able to feel the wind on
your face you know the Sun on your face
they're they're very much is there's
something called sensory deprivation and
your sensory system starts to kind of
download over time and that affects you
psychologically that can lead to
depression anxiety or just a sense of
detachment it can disrupt your sleep and
it can start to affect your health and
so that's why it's very important for us
to have things within the station within
our environment that can kind of bring
that
back and there it can be anything from
the the fabrics and in the uniform or
the clothes that you're wearing to the
kinds of food that you're eating texture
it's really important to entertainment
diversion humor interaction touch
feeling all of these things are so
important and the habitats clearly the
place where we're actually going to live
is is key to much of this so nASA has
and partners have launched the 3d
printed habitat challenge design
competition to create the optimum
Martian housing we can see some
different versions I think yeah here we
have some of the some of these images
Michelle
how does 3d printing help you talked a
little bit about how it helps us fix
things well I mean you can create
something while you're there how does
that work with this you would just have
a bunch of these 3d printers they're a
couple guys on my team went and watched
the this competition and they said it
was really pretty pretty amazing
meaning I think one of the winning teams
used a slurry a mixture of materials
they have these industrial sized 3d
printers now I think the theirs they're
starting to use them in construction
with concrete the challenges of course
with the nozzles clogging up things like
that but yes so 3d printing is not just
for making habitats for making tools
we've actually practiced since some of
some of the analog missions we've 3d
printed tools on demand instead of
having to take a whole big gigantic
toolbox right you may be you could just
print just very yeah okay so the idea
here is that you'd live in one of these
things Ellen what about the idea of
living in a lava tube underground could
we do that it would certainly give you
that radiation protection you need at
least a meter so at least three if feet
if not six feet of rock to protect you
really from that radiation so ultimately
if we want to stay on Mars for a long
time we've got to get out of the way of
that radiation and so a lava tube would
be a way to do it now obviously that
presents challenges because now you're
back
an artificial light environment you're
not in a real light environment that has
psychological effects and so it's but
it's a really good option in terms of
human protection and it's already there
so you don't have to worry about about
creating that radiation protection so we
know the lava tubes are there it means
are we planning on landing near any of
them
those have been looked at as possible
future landing sites okay okay point
there's another reason to be interested
in lava tubes and it ties back to the
same thing which is the radiation
protection if there was life on Mars it
would also need protection from
radiation and so lava tubes are really
good place to look for signs of past or
even possibly present life because it
would be protected there and also
there's other reasons as well it's more
stable in the temperature it's a place
where you know water and various forms
might be found so it would be a really
good place to start looking I didn't
want to bring up one thing in a Vaughn
can can amplify this much better since
I'm a geologist not a doctor um but you
know the reason radiation is bad for you
is that it breaks your DNA and those
breaks lead to things like cancer so it
happens that some of us are actually
better at repairing our DNA than others
your DNA is always repairing itself at
some point those repair mechanisms break
down so this is a really critical area
of research again space benefiting life
here on earth the more we understand how
to repair radiation damage so that maybe
we can learn to live with radiation I
think helps us live on Mars but it also
helps us live on earth and that brings
up the subject not only of radiation
damage but of germs in general what are
we going to do
first of all to combat any viruses germs
you tell me what can what can attack and
at what point do we have to worry about
contaminating the environment in some
way I do have one piece of good news on
that which is that if you send a crew of
say six people they are very quickly
going to share all of the germs that
they are going to see for a long time so
we found that our crews is after maybe
an initial period
they just didn't really get sick because
they built up an immunity than everybody
else's germs the problem is then when
they came out and then interact with the
rest of the population again they all
got sick oh well okay well we're not
coming back for a while so we'll see but
we are coming back we are coming back
Yvonne but what about general health
issues while we're living there
general health issues will you touched
on one thing that's important our
galactic responsibility we want to make
sure that we don't contaminate a planet
that we're trying to learn more about
and lighting and UV can help with that
but it doesn't do a whole lot to protect
us so we're going to be exposed to
micros between each other maybe microbes
that we don't even know the microbiome
of other possibly alien life-forms but
also we're going to evolve and change to
our immune systems will be stressed
because of radiation the flight lack of
sleep other medical issues that are
going on but also we're going to change
our own microbiome and we may not be as
tolerant of ourselves as when we left
the planet so all of these things are
very important to us to think about what
happens to the genetic code if we become
too restrictive now we could put
ourselves in a bubble and make things
very protected from us in both
directions but what does that do to our
resiliency and we found over time that
one of the reasons we've been able to
persist as a human species is this
intermingling of the environment and
micro biomes so maybe we do want to
interact and maybe that's part of the
code of human survivability somewhere
else
what are we eating by the way please
tell me it's not potatoes now we get to
open it up a little bit you know
something one of the reasons I love that
movie is before it came out people were
very skeptical about the food research
we do it i sees they've told us give
your astronauts a protein pill they'll
be fine and now all I have to say is
remember when you ran out of ketchup but
yes so one of the joys of being on a
planetary surface even with less gravity
than the earth is there's enough gravity
and enough a little bit more space so
you're gonna be able to cook and there's
a lot of good reasons to do that one is
that bulk stored ingredients are much
easier to keep shelf stable and highly
nutritious for these long durations so
you know a bag of flour is going to last
a lot longer than a sealed in piece of
bread another is that there's less
packaging and when you're going to Mars
masses everything so we're gonna be
making our own bread is what you're
telling is what I'm telling you yeah and
then the other part is this
combinatorics so you know if you if
you've got a lasagna pre-prepared
lasagna it's always gonna be a lasagna
but if you give someone noodles and
tomato powder and herbs and spices and
cheese powder they can combine these
things in a bunch of different ways so
you get a much larger range of possible
meals I know in the habitat will that be
earth gravity or will that be moon Mars
gravity Mars gravity yeah that's not
really okay in the current Mars
gravity's what a third a third earth so
you can cook okay
in a third gravity some things are gonna
work differently but yeah you know okay
you still wouldn't want an open flame
that would be a terrible thing but but
back to 3d printers 3d print food 3d
print me neat 3d print the pizza some of
these things already we're even finding
ways to 3d print body parts like nose
and ears injury off planet is a whole
different situation but it can add to
the whole stress and quality of your
experience when you're sick or injured
so we need to find ways to accelerate
and amplify our our own rejuvenation and
really leverage the body's capacity to
heal itself but I think 3d printing is
wonderful maiden spaces our 3d printer
up there right now and not only have
they demonstrated how we can 3d print
and how we can exchange CAD drawings
with people here on earth but there was
an incident not too long ago a couple of
years ago or so where we needed a
special tool and they were able it would
have meant flying a whole nother vehicle
to deliver the tool and we
were able to do the CAD drawing 3d
printed successfully and voila you have
it so I think that's a great way to give
Christmas presents ability holiday
presents or any kind of present for any
celebration back on earth is to have
something that we design on space and
you kind of get a CAD design space
version of some sort of 3d printed gift
so we're celebrating holidays definitely
every holiday okay we're celebrating
holidays we're eating we're gonna be
having food I bet we're growing our own
food okay can we have babies let's see
what we've been able to determine so far
from what we've seen is that
physiologically the reproductive system
seems to be somewhat protected from the
presence or absence of gravity so
physiologically you're physiologically
ambivalent to the gravity in your
environment things still function
fortunately for our heart our lungs and
other body processes on the other hand
we've actually conducted a seminar on
Pediatrics in space so we are
anticipating pioneering in space to the
point where we have a community with
children and what that might look like
there's a gap in between we haven't
quite resolved yet but again we're very
much committed to demonstrating proof of
concept okay
[Laughter]
the phrase that only NASA generations of
fruit flies I wasn't talking about I'm
sorry okay I'll hold it no no okay a
couple more specifics a Martian day is a
little bit longer than an Earth Day how
many hours is a Martian doing about 39
minutes longer 39 minutes longer and
what do we call a Martian day a soul
okay how many how many souls or how many
souls in an earth year or how many how
many earth days in a Martian year I
guess it's the one twice as long the
marsh voice is long and we have seasons
seasons and we have a day/night cycle
day/night cycle okay this is like home
do we have snow frost frost no it
doesn't snow and frost doesn't know but
we have frost and we have wind storms
you've talked about that but but the
wind storms are not Martian movie wind
storms the atmosphere on Mars is very
thin and it's not gonna knock anything
over even in a huge windstorm so you do
have dust storms and you do have wind
but again the atmospheric density is so
low that rain no no rain so nothing is
coming down through that it's all
somehow coming up okay condense it down
in the atmosphere it's difficult what
you're describing is a difficult
situation we're not we're not going to
land and then go running around and send
postcards home and isn't this wonderful
this is a real commitment make the case
for me why should somebody want to do
this I'm from Alaska so it's not all bad
it was second ISM some people in the
desert Southwest when they look at
photos of Mars that looks like home to
them
so it was described as sort of like the
desert Southwest so
when you you know for you live in New
York City so you look at pictures of
Mars and that doesn't look very inviting
no but I the pictures promoting this
there was a whole city was a good
restaurant scene you ready you know my
answer is scientific we're gonna we're
pretty sure the conditions on early Mars
were not that different than the
conditions on early Earth when life
evolved and to me the real myth is for
humans is to be have a lot of geologists
and astrobiologists up there cracking
open rocks not only finding out that
life did evolve on Mars but finding the
extent to which it became complex
finding the extent to which it's
different than life on Earth and that
just doesn't take one rock sample it
takes hundreds and hundreds of fossils
to allow you to really understand that
that takes humans that takes at least a
scientific base on the surface and what
oh go ahead Kim can I add to that cuz
that absolutely is the main scientific
motivation and for me but there's also a
bit of a I want us to make earth our
home your home you only start talking
about your home when you leave it and
you return to it so you don't when
you're a kid your town is just town you
only talk about it is your hometown when
you leave it and come back and so I
would like humanity to be able to leave
Earth live somewhere else for a little
while and then come back to their home
planet and I hope that perspective would
help us treat it the way it ought to be
treated before we get further into why
Mars Michele how do we get back we need
to just make the case that we're coming
back here how do we do that that is the
to me that's the most exciting part so
the the asset vehicle the thing that's
gonna get us back off of Mars so that we
can come back home to me that's the
crown jewel of the whole engineering
feat and that's something we haven't we
haven't done all of the missions we've
sent to Mars to date have all been
one-way missions so developing an asset
vehicle we hope to be able to pattern
after the asset vehicle that we'll be
building for the moon
ideally same cabin maybe a little bit
different propulsion system there's more
gravity on Mars there's a little bit of
an atmosphere so we need a little bit
more boost to get off of the planet then
we belong the moon but we're hoping
there's a lot of synergy in those
technologies so we are coming back okay
with that in mind before we finish up
before we go further here can we have
the lights up a little I'd like to ask a
question how many of you in this
audience and one see by hands would like
to take a trip to Mars and come back
that's a fair number of hands okay how
many of you would be willing to go to
Mars and stay there and live for a
couple of years oh I see hands I see
hands okay fascinating so then you would
go and not come back okay good question
and may I introduce our doctor we could
dim the lights again if you will
Avon is on the record as saying she
wants to go and live there why well we
call it pioneering and it's because well
first of all first and foremost it's the
only way to know is to go and so
exploration has always been a part of
the human spirit and it's the curiosity
the passion the discovery that are our
tools are true vehicles to get us there
and the only way to know yourself is to
go in search of yourself so until we
really go and push the envelope we don't
know the full envelope capability
capacity of the human envelope and to me
that's just something that has to be not
just known but the journey to get there
is really the reward whether we find out
the complete answer at the destination
are you speaking of the journey of you
Yvonne Cagle as an individual or the
journey of all of us as Carl an answer
to Carl Sagan's words
you know I aspire to go off planet to
pioneer Mars and I can only hope that
not only should I have the privilege to
go but when I get there that Karl will
be there that you will be there and that
all of you will be there too so you're
doing it in part for everybody and with
everybody it's interesting the word that
is used for putting these habitats
bringing people to Mars doing all this
is terraforming what is terraforming
mean and what's it about
so terraforming is there have been
scientific papers written about it as
well as many many science fiction books
it is could we take Mars and actually
turn it into an earth-like environment
so basically could we cause the
atmosphere to become more dense more
oxygen-rich so that you could walk
around on the surface we could go grow
crops out on the surface without having
to live in a pressurized habitat so
there again scientific papers that have
been written on it that say it's it's
feasible the problem is the mechanisms
that have been discussed take hundreds
of millions of years and then of course
you have to maintain that atmosphere
again Mars lacks a magnetic field
without a magnetic field the solar wind
is constantly stripping the upper layers
the atmosphere away so the more you were
building an atmosphere on Mars the more
the solar winds starting to strip it
away so it's a I think it's pretty tough
I I tend to keep it in the science
fiction category myself
everybody has 3d glasses we're now going
to look at some extraordinary images
that nASA has 3d eyes to give us a
better idea of what it's going to look
like you've heard everyone talking about
in sort of Arizona or the Southwest
let's take a look and and our panel is
going to try to explain what we're
looking at if not where what we see from
this all right this is a one of the
Kasbah on Mars it's a it's a beautiful
chasm that you can see from all those
layered deposits in the interior it's
been used by water at some point so
that's a partially water
carved channel on the surface those
holes you see all over the place are
impact craters and the fact if you look
on the right side of the image you'll
see there were very few impact craters
on that high plateau on the left side of
the image there are lots of craters the
longer a surface is exposed the more
craters it collects so I can tell you
right away
those are two different geologic units
one is much younger than the other and
we don't Ellen have any idea what the
scale of this is is that right no we
don't unfortunately my guess is it's
probably it's that chasm that chasm is
probably a couple kilometers across is
my guess but I'm not quite sure where
this is I'd also just like to point out
that the depth on this has been
exaggerated you know it's it looks much
deeper than it it would be in real life
okay
next picture this is a great obviously
perspective view or way they've been
draping an image over topographic
information of the surface to give you
this multi Canyon view of these
beautiful Hills on Mars again vertically
exaggerated but not not quite as much as
the previous image really beautiful
sculpted terrain on Mars Mars has been
heavily eroded by water and also the
rocks are worn by the wind and covered
in dust and I just think this is a
gorgeous image it is gorgeous whoa that
one's freaking my eyes
these look like little volcanic Peaks
almost I'm not sure where this is
actually but really a beautiful image
and some actual sand dunes down in the
valley there on the right side of the
image that's our little Sojourner Rover
this is one of the landing sites from
Pathfinder those are solar panels on top
of that little rover and you can see
it's gonna go make fries yeah that rock
how big is so dramatic how big is
Sojourner Sojourner is about this bout
of less than a foot tall a foot long
tiny we've got one in the National Air
and Space Museum in Washington DC Oh
course of that this is an impact crater
it looks like with sand dunes on the
base of it y'all let that loose material
inside has been blown into all those
ripples which are sand dunes looks like
water doesn't this is another impact
greater impact from an asteroid probably
uh yeah and these are beautiful
beautiful sand dunes we talked about
dust storms earlier a lot of dust on
Mars blown around by the wind forms into
beautiful dunes that are again pretty
analogous to dunes that that we see here
on earth I love this image this is the
inside the wall of an impact crater but
if you look along the rim of it you can
see where there's almost been landslides
of material those kind of smooth
triangular deposits that head down
towards the floor of the crater
oh so this is probably a skylight into a
lava tube what do you think so it's a
little hard to tell without the context
but we see lava tubes on earth volcanoes
such as in Hawaii and we see what we're
pretty sure lava tubes on Mars so
they're really really long caves and
then every once in a while the ceiling
falls in so if you can see the hole on
the left the ceiling is falling in you
can kind of just see the tube continuing
off towards the top of the image and
again there's that material that's
gathered been blown in there on the
inside this is almost certainly a
skylight I'd say yeah it makes you want
to go and put a habitat in there it
certainly does
this is Curiosity rover and Gale Crater
background and Gale Crater has been an
amazing place for curiosity to explore
what we found out over the years is that
from all the rocks that curiosity has
studied is that in the past again about
three and a half billion 3.8 billion
years ago this place was potentially
habitable so we don't know that it was
inhabited but the conditions were there
that would have been conducive to the
formation of life and those are the 3d
images extraordinary you don't need your
glasses anywhere
so as Ellen was saying earlier we know a
lot and we know a lot before we get
there and we're gonna know a lot more
after we get there and when we come back
which some of us are doing except for
Yvonne we'll be telling you all about it
just quick final thoughts when's this
gonna happen when do you think we'll be
there anybody says we have to we'll
sorry I said as soon as we have the will
to get this we have the will okay I'll
accept that and what happens after Mars
do we go to other planets or isn't as
Mars occupy us for a very long time we
not only go to other planets we go to
asteroids we go to other galaxies
ultimately as we learn how to do this
better but yeah we just keep going we
just say go then and with that I want to
say thank you to the panel and let me
let me just mention the first science
fiction movie I ever saw we're talking
about this earlier was a movie called
destination moon it's a pretty awful
black and white really tacky movie but
but I was a little very little kid and I
was astounded and here's the part that
really astounded me at the very end of
this dumb plot nonetheless it was it was
a rocket and it was going to the moon at
the very end there was a crawl curls
when the words come up on the screen and
at the very end of the movie it said
this is the end
dot-dot-dot of the beginning and I
thought oh my goodness we're really
going to do this
so I'm now here to say we're really
going to do this thank you all very much
thank you very much
you
[Music]